it's the beginning of March 2019 so
that's time for another monthly update
video which I'll talk about what we've
got coming up this month and what went
on in the month of February I always
like to begin by highlighting three big
things that I figure you subscribers
viewers other fans might might be
interested in so one of these is
particularly big and that's big thing
number one we will pass the 500 mark in
the philosophy core concepts series and
I'm going to have a little online party
about that and I invite you to join me
so more about that in March another
thing coming up this month big thing
number two we will have a video premiere
on redoing and rethinking my how to
study Plato independently on your own
video because I want to start doing a
series about this Plato is the place for
me to start and so you can look out for
that coming up later this month
and the big thing number three is I have
done a month worth of writing interacts
st and i went again not every single day
but i've successfully transitioned it
into my sort of updates and short
thoughts blog so if you haven't checked
that out you probably want to have a lot
of new content coming this month in or
excist you know educating my main blog
so what went on in the month of february
february is always a short month that
comes sandwiched in between two longer
months when you can actually get things
done it seems like there's never enough
days in the month anyway and February
it's particularly compressed I also had
some illnesses I'm still sick right now
I've got some scientists think oh my god
but I did end up using a few sick days
and not teaching quite as much but I
didn't manage to get some some things
done so I I had events on Epictetus
in the philosopher of the midst of
history series we have a talk here
have not yet put the video out for that
we'll be doing that later this week I
also had a talk in the monthly worlds of
speculative fiction series that we host
here locally with the Brookfield public
library and we talked about G K
Chesterton somebody who I'm a big fan of
the video for that is available and
you'll find it below I also did a
workshop here at a local college for the
philosophy majors it's one of my sort of
stock workshops that I do from time to
time centered on how you actually make a
living with a philosophy degree without
becoming a philosophy instructor and so
the undergraduates were very interested
in that understandably so I do that both
for undergraduate and graduate students
and I also by the way as a sideline help
people who are in academia transition
out of it and find you know remunerative
stuff to do it is quite possible to make
a living outside of the traditional
academy but a lot of people don't even
think about this so that was a lot of
fun to do
I had my heifer Hegel online sessions
did my am made and my philosophy pop ups
this month focused on stoicism and
romantic relationships and you know did
did quite a few other things as well I
am still teaching my five college and
university classes so that demands quite
a lot of you know doing content
production a lot of grading a lot of
lecturing but I do enjoy doing all that
that work it's just there is an awful
lot of it and I did start getting more
writing done in not only my author blog
or access to you know at 2 K which I've
decided to start writing much shorter
pieces and you know updates and things
like that not necessarily every single
day but but I'm aiming to try to get you
know something done most days in there
to use it in a different way and I
decided that I would do my longer form
writing on places like medium or you
know of course it's
and today I've got a piece that will be
coming up later this month there or the
partially examine live or I you know
I've got if I want to I can pitch things
to the conversation I'm thinking that
now it's time for me to do my longer
form popular writing in these other
electronic venues I did some you know
video work I only got one half hour
hagel video done this month mostly due
to the illness factor coming up at bad
times I shot quite a few core concept
videos mostly for my classes someone say
and some some James Rachel's challenge
of cultural relativism I shot some
kohlberg material Lawrence Kohlberg on
moral development that I haven't
released yet accepted my patreon
supporters and I shot some other core
concept material as well and I also you
know produced the event videos you can
see all of those if you look below in
the video description so that really
took up most of the month and I think if
I hadn't have gotten sick well I had so
much work on my plate I probably would
have been able to get everything done
for the month that I wanted to but you
know alas that happens so now I'm doing
a lot of catch-up what have we got
coming up in the month of March so let
me tell you first about events put them
on your calendar jot them down however
you want to some of them are online so
you could participate in them pretty
much anywhere some of them are local so
we start off with a online event my
monthly AMA that's asked me anything
session which I will be holding on this
coming Saturday the 9th at 12 p.m.
Central Time make sure that you check
your time zones especially if you're in
a place that doesn't observe daylight
savings time you want to make sure you
know find out what what you know time it
is in Chicago and that's the time that
we are up here in Milwaukee so I'll be
doing that AMA and then on the 10th
which is Sunday I'm going to
hold an online celebration and I haven't
quite worked out all the details but I'm
going to do that about our 500 core
concept videos where actually I went and
then looked at the thing today the
playlist there's 497 so with the things
I'm going to release this week we will
be at 500 if not past that and I invite
you to come and hang out with me a bit
and we'll talk about you know what I've
got coming up maybe I'll do it in an
online video format like with the AMAs
maybe I'll do it with video conferencing
I got to think through how exactly I'm
going to do it but it will be on the
10th at 4 p.m. so make sure that you
come in for that and then on the 12th
which is a Tuesday we'll have a 4 p.m.
we'll have our public Haegele Q&A
discussion session that is video
conferencing so you can talk to me live
ask me questions about Hegel bring up
other stuff from German idealism or
applicability of Hegel to things open to
the public it's something that that I do
as a public service funded by my patreon
supporters then on the 14th if you're
here in the Greater Milwaukee area at
the Brookfield Public Library 7:00 p.m.
we're going to have another one of the
worlds of speculative fiction series and
this time we're discussing Mary Shelley
and of course everybody is read
Frankenstein in high school or at least
you know read about it and that is a
really important work and it's quite a
good piece of literature but she wrote
other things as well including other
things about you know utopia's or
dystopian other really interesting
material so we're going to talk about
Frankenstein of course but we'll talk
about her larger move right her corpus
and go into that and why do we pick Mary
Shelley because she's so important as an
early science fiction horror gothic pick
all these different genres right
then on the sixteenth which is a
Saturday we got two things coming up and
12:00 p.m. Central Standard Time I will
be doing a video premiere of my you know
video essentially talking about how can
you study Plato on your own productively
I'll be giving you tips insights my own
experience and talking about what you
might want to get and what you might
want to keep in mind and you can
interact with me live well it is
premiering then at 3 p.m. we'll have our
philosophy chat for patreon supporters
and that's a video conferencing again if
you want to you know get to chat with me
and that that's open to anytime anything
people want to bring up a little do
philosophy chat about that the last
thing is on Thursday the 28th very end
of the month at 6 p.m. at the short Wood
Public Library we have the MKE stoic
fellowship meeting we do this monthly we
will be talking about the beginning of
book 4 of Epictetus discourses there's a
very very long chapter there on freedom
and we'll talk about you know how we
apply this in our day to day lives and
whether making any progress with
stoicism or not so those are the events
there's already quite a lot going on I'm
still teaching in my classes of course
March is a real important turnaround
time this is make or break for many of
the students and it's you know we're
halfway through and now we got to keep
on plowing away but we do at least have
spring break for the Marquette and
Milwaukee Institute of Art Design
students not from never MATC there in
April but I'll have at least a week
where I get to catch up myself and get
everything ready for the students as
they move on with the material probably
doing a lot of grading too and I'm
hoping to do a lot more writing this
month as I mentioned I'll be having a
piece coming out in Stoicism today
either this week
or the weekend after you should look for
my work in media you could follow the
link below to my my profile or you can
find my writings or xst and Ont k if
you're not you know following my main
author blog you might want to check that
up since then updates about events
giveaways cool stuff as well as my
musings from from day to day that I put
down in there so if you want to know
what a philosopher is thinking about
there you go and there'll be other
venues as well and I'll put
announcements for that in might my
social media I'm going to be working on
some course design stuff mostly for
academic courses but eventually it all
that stuff will go into the teachable
Academy as well which means that you can
actually either purchase the courses
some of them are available at a price
some of them are actually free but you
know we'll see what I can bring to out
not this month but in coming months
last thing I need to talk about really
is is video work and I really want to
get back on track shooting those those
six half-hour hagel videos so that we're
not spending forever in this spirit
section of the phenomenology and we can
get into the religion section which
means that we're getting close to the
end of the work it's been six years that
I've put in on this this project so you
know it's about time I actually brought
it to a close I'm gonna be doing some
core concept videos what I'm shooting
now is stuff on Thomas Aquinas Lord well
I shot the kohlberg I'll be releasing
that sort of stuff and also be shooting
stuff on Rene Descartes David Hume and I
think I'm going to be shooting some
stuff on Ansem and his dialogue freedom
of the will and I might go back and
shoot some stuff on Augustine that I
didn't get to if I can find the time
I'll be also shooting that self-study
Play Doh video and of course there will
be a recording of the mary shelley
discussion of the AMA of some of the
other things as well so
if you miss them you'll have a chance to
see them later on and I am trying to set
aside time to get back into doing the
podcast you know the taking my lectures
and turning them into things that you
could listen to online wherever you go
that's a matter of finding the time and
I hey you know well we'll see how that
works this this coming month so that is
everything that's going on hope all of
you have a great month of March and
maybe it's time to get a lot of things
done as we finish up the first quarter
of the year
you